hello there I'm Conan O'Brien welcome to
serious jibber-jabber I'm sitting here
with a contributing editor and theater
critic for Time magazine who's written
this really terrific biography of the
legendary comedian Bob Hope entitled
hope I've been waiting for a great book
about Bob Hope for 30 years and it's
here and I'm very happy to be joined by
Richard Soglin thanks for being here
Richard to be here I true story and
we'll just lay this on the table I heard
that a great biography of Hope had come
out I read some great reviews I went and
got it
I secluded myself and digested this book
completely loved it and when I was done
I thought this guy got it right and
hoped deserved a great biography and now
he has one so congratulations
I'm really glad that you wrote this book
and then I just sent you a fan letter on
my 1917 Underwood typewriter and that
led to us realizing that we could come
together and talk about the great Bob
Hope here today yes well you know I
thought - Bob Hope it was funny looking
over all the biographies all the
Hollywood greats most of them have had
really major biographies but sometimes
two three four Sinatra crosby you know
Cary Grant you name it
Bob Hope had been there had been some
biographies but nothing really really
good and so it was a real lack there and
I sort of jumped in well here's the
interesting thing
you know Bob Hope was and I don't think
people appreciate this today but few
entertainers in comedy
have ever done or probably no one has
ever done what Bob Hope did which was a
massive star in movies radio he then
made that he transformed into television
right cessful II there wasn't a medium I
don't think that he didn't can't go back
he started in vaudeville vaudeville he
he did Broadway theater people Donnie
remember today he was a fairly
substantial Broadway star in the 30s he
moved into radio movies television and
all that time he was doing personal
appearances you know at a rate that no
other star of his stature could maintain
and he did it into his 80s right it was
amazing
he was obviously for my generation it
what's interesting is that we see a
different hope my generation grew up
with this different Bob Hope I started
really seeing Bob Hope on television in
the 70s and then into the 80s and I
associate it with stuff I mean Senate
Live was big at the time SCTV he's very
hip edgy shows yeah Bob Hope would do
these primetime specials where he and
John Forsythe were dressed as Cabbage
Patch dolls with Brooke Shields and you
know not to not to sound snarky but it
was not my cup of tea it seemed it
seemed old it seemed crusty it seemed
like who's you know square
you know who's watching this and so
that's the Bob Hope that I first knew
and and I think a lot of generation of
people that I worked with in comedy
thought of Bob Hope that way this kind
of sticky joke machine right he's
corporate he's wearing the Texaco blazer
and then as I really got her sitting
comedy I started to see his early work
in the road pictures right and I was
completely blown away yeah by how effing
good Bob Hope was just perfect yeah I
grew up with those movies too there was
they were so great and Bob Hope's the TV
work it did get very stale pretty pretty
quick but he he was the old style of
comedian of course he had writers he was
he was there was no real personality in
Bob Hope's comedy he was he was a joke
machine and he used writers and this of
course in the 60s when the the sort of
stand-up comedy revolution happened and
George Carlin Richard Pryor and so forth
Robert Klein and everybody you know they
wrote their own material their stand-up
comedy was an expression of themselves
or their
political views or whatever Bob was
still doing you're right that sort of
corporate impersonal stand-up but you
have to go back to see how much of an
innovator he was first of all in
stand-up comedy I mean I really think he
invented the form at least the form that
we know it a guy getting up there and
telling jokes about what was happening
in the world I mean when he came along
he went on he come on to radio in 1938
and the people who are big radio stars
at the time the comedians well Jack
Benny and Burns and Allen and Bergen and
McCarthy and they all did jokes about
their own little world
you know Jack Benny was the stingy guy
and there was Rochester right now and
he's got the old car yeah it's got a
basement with money and it was funny
stuff but it it had nothing to do with
the outside world ahead to do with his
little world
Burns and Allen routines Bob Hope came
into that world and he said he hired a
bunch of writers and more that writers
than any other radio show around and he
said look we're gonna have to this
show's gonna rise or fall on the jokes
we're gonna do an opening monologue read
the papers get me you know jokes out of
the out of the news or the politics or
Holly what's happening in Hollywood or
even Bob's own life and you know this
was something new here's a stand-up
comedian making jokes about the world
and that was kind of the invention of
the topical monologue which of course
everybody's done Sam know the topical
monologue you know people my generation
probably thinks well it started with
Johnny Carson that's as far back as it
goes and it really does really I think
you're right I think probably starts
with Bob Hope mm-hmm telling jokes and
then he became the joke teller the emcee
for America I think he hosted the Oscars
17 times or something was actually
hosting or co-hosting 19 times 19 leave
it or not yeah 17 well live that's right
I know I'm kidding but nobody he I
remembered he was the guy who who's
friends with pretty much every president
yeah I think not Jimmy Carter well he
knew Carter
I mean who Carter but there wasn't he
couldn't connect it as close to cousin
is close to Carter but pretty
every president could call in Bob Hope
yeah and Bob Hope would be the emcee for
some event he was friends with them he
played golf with them and people don't
realize that at the height of his
popularity he had it there's a Bob Hope
comic book yeah there's Bob Hope
merchandise he used to write books that
were big my bestsellers that were sort
of comic silly books that were written a
lot probably by his gagman mostly he was
the original multimedia star we talk
about branding today he was the first
really Hollywood star to figure out the
power of his own brand yes so he he
branched out he wrote he started writing
memoirs when he was barely in Hollywood
he already had much of a career to talk
about but he would write these memoirs
or on his trips overseas and and then he
wrote a newspaper column for several
years into the Hearst syndicate he had
this comic book and of course then the
golf tournament so he was the Bob Hope
Brandt how many how many stars had had
their own logo you know that little you
know profile with the nose and the chin
yeah recognized the iconic sloped nose
and you know Jerry Lewis later I guess
had that in the in the 50s the and Jerry
Lewis into his 90s I think still uses
that see yeah the one when he was 20 the
same logo I'll use my logo forever with
the hair yeah which by now is just you
know polyurethane but what's interesting
there's so many things interesting about
Bob Hope but he did use writers he
valued writers and he would talk about
his writers write in as part of his act
you know and I need to pay my writers
more and I keep my jokes in a joke file
and there was a it became part of his
personality was that he had writers and
I think that contrasted him I don't know
if you agree with this but you think
about the singers of the 30s and 40s and
50s they sang standards that were
written by other people exactly
then Beatles and Bob Dylan and there's
this whole movement that comes along
where people write their own songs
because that's the truth right and there
almost feels like there's a little bit
of a bias that
lair stand-ups who wrote their own
material Mike I don't know I don't say
they look down on but maybe feel
separated from a guy who's reading
someone else they feel that they're not
in the same business sort of and that
their their comedy is more personal and
and more sincere and committed sort of
yeah and that may be true but Bob Hope
did but the the comparison with singers
is is exactly right because do we say
that Frank Sinatra was not a great
artist because he didn't write his own
songs no he was a great interpreter Bob
Hope didn't write those jokes but he he
picked the jokes he put them in the
right order he he sometimes edited them
he would edit to the you know he would
take out every excess word and he knew
how to deliver him and that's a huge
talent too he is one of if not the maybe
the smoothest performer he's so exact
he's so good you look at him especially
in those in the early movies you look at
him in the 30s and throughout the 40s
and into the 50s and he is so graceful
and his timing is impeccable yes and it
took me a while to see it I remembered
years ago hearing that Woody Allen said
oh I so much from Bob Hope now that
didn't make sense then I first heard it
because I was thinking of the Bob Hope
of 1986 you know and what does he have
to do with Woody Allen yeah what did you
could understand what Woody Allen could
have possibly borrowed from Bob Hope you
go back and you look at the old movies
and you look at his performances and Bob
Hope had invented this guy who's back on
his heels right nervous talking right ah
a coward yeah but wisecracking but also
trying not to offend and trying to get
out of a jam and trying to just kind of
and then you think wait these are all
these are also Woody Allen mannerisms
that cut the whole the whole Woody Allen
in Annie Hall tearing up the parking the
the ticket is it I don't do well with
it's not it's not you don't take it
personally it is all it's the Jewish
version the Jewish American comics
version of Bob Hope yeah yeah that was
the character that he discovered sort of
it started in 1939 with the film a
Catholic canary comedy haunted house
film and Bob is one of a bunch of
relatives in the you know reading a will
is weird things going on in the house
and Bob is the nervous relative and and
someone says to him don't bend big empty
houses scary you he says not me I was in
vaudeville
but that was that that was the start of
it and then he just developed that
character in every kind of movie service
comedies and and in you know
eighteenth-century romantic comedies
that he was always that guy in any
situation almost almost anyone yeah uh
you know I should take us back because
there's a lot of things that people
don't appreciate about Bob Hope he was a
massive star and I think one of the
great comedy performers of all time what
people don't know is that he wasn't he
was an immigrant he was not born in the
United States born in Wales no born in
England just outside of London okay it
is not his mother I think was Welsh
that's it yeah and the family he lived
there only till four and a half it's
when the family emigrated his father was
a stonemason not a very good provider
alcoholic you know in and out of jobs
move the family around a lot they moved
around in England they were in several
different towns until finally his father
moved to America to look for work moved
to Cleveland brought the family over a
bob grew up in Cleveland and work grew
up poor yeah father still wasn't making
a very good living the mother was very
resourceful rented out rooms in their
house had boarders all the boys there
were seven boys in the family bob was
fifth of seven and each boy you know
each kid had to go to work to help the
family out and it was a tough immigrant
neighborhood you know on the east side
of Cleveland and
you know tough bob didn't didn't
graduate high school may have done some
time in reforms you did to say that's
the one one of the things I discovered
in the book bob was always vague about
why he dropped out of high school you
know wanted to get into show business
but he he never revealed that he was it
was sent to reform school he was
arrested for something that the the
arrest records have been removed
I wonder by who but I kind of assumed it
was shoplifting or something he used to
joke about shoplifting Sporting Goods
when he was a kid
and he spent two stints in reform school
they released him and then he broke
parole and sent back so any you know
that was the end of his schooling it's
kind of funny that he never mentioned it
you know it seems like he liked to joke
about his scrappy
Cleveland childhood I don't know what's
so so terrible about spending some time
in reform school yeah but he didn't he
he wiped that out if he not good for the
brand
maybe not a maybe not but he was a boxer
he boxed under the name [ __ ] East today
and and we're talking about a very poor
guy who's really trying to make it and
trying everything and one of the things
that really comes across in your book
that startled me is how long it took Bob
Hope to make it to really catch on you
just he's so good and he lights up the
screen and he's so talented and
charismatic and then you realized that
he tried and tried and tried and tried
and you know it took him forever to get
a career going in vaudeville mm-hmm he
has spent go have an 89 years in
vaudeville he started out with various
partners he would do a dance he was kind
of a song and dance and comedy guy and
he had a part of different partners they
did pretty well you know he travelled
around the Midwest small-time circuit
and and then he broke off and tried on
his own and he he started working as an
emcee and that's where he kind of
developed his comedy style because most
of the comedian's all the comedian's in
vaudeville had their routines you know
they were the funny Irishman or the
fright you know and they would take that
that same routine from city to city bob
was an MC and he had to kind of ad-lib
improvise on stage you know introduce
the acts stretch the show cut you know
whatever you know fill the time and so
he had to you know he would throw in
jokes and he would you know vary it from
night tonight and that's where he got a
more conversational sort of comedy style
it was not that common in vaudeville but
he he worked his way up he was
eventually playing the Palace Theater
who big you know vaudeville theater but
he still you know wasn't making it he
had a screen test in Hollywood in 1930
and he failed it yeah I read that in the
book and it surprised me right I I don't
know he he puts it down he says I you
know he couldn't stand it
but what for whatever reason they didn't
think he would work he was a bit of a on
on screen he was a very sophisticated
New York you know a Broadway type and he
was different
and I just I think he was maybe a little
too brittle and sophisticated for for
Hollywood at that time so he went back
to then he you know continue to work in
vaudeville and moved his way worked his
way up but it was finally after about
eight or nine years he broke into
Broadway and he got a lead one of the
leading roles in a Broadway show his big
show was Roberta in 1933 the song that's
thanks for the memories so that was that
was that came later in the movies the
big song from Roberta was smoke gets in
your eyes which was sung to Bob Hope
he didn't zing but he thanks for the
memory came in 1938 when he spent five
years in Broadway and then finally
Paramount Pictures gave him a contract
lured him out to Hollywood even though
he kept claiming he didn't want anything
to do with Hollywood he was a
sophisticated Broadway leading man
he didn't need Hollywood but they gave
him a good contract he went out and he
appeared in big broadcast and at 7:30
a.m. with he was you know fifth or sixth
on the bill WC Fields was the lead
Dorothy Lamour was in it
Martha Raye was in it and but Bob and
and Shirley Ross got the big the
number in the show which was thanks for
the memory in if you ever get a chance
to look at that scene and it's on
YouTube you could it's easy to see but
Bob and Shirley Ross singing thanks to
the memory you realize what a wonderful
song that is how much emotion is in the
song they perform it beautifully it's
beautifully directed and that was the
scene that made Bob Hope a movie star
and then it became his song yeah me not
even know I just knew that if I was
watching Johnny Carson when I was a kid
and Johnny was talking and then suddenly
you heard that it meant that Bob Hope
was crashing the set to make a surprise
appearance as part of the branding yeah
exactly and so I didn't even know I
didn't know I knew that that song just
meant that Bob Hope has come front and I
didn't know the the story behind it or
anything
what was also unusual about him was he
was one of the great ad livers he's
incredible ad-libber he had prepared
jokes but he was also and I guess he
learned that from vaudeville as well he
people yeah he used writers was Bob
people asked me was Bob Hope really
funny you know or a busy guy who could
just read jokes he was funny people
writers who worked for him Larry Gelbart
for example said Bob Hope was was
funnier in person than any of his
monologues I mean he really was a fun
guy to be with he just had a natural wit
and I you could see it sometimes in you
know the TV shows and radio to where you
know they had flubs on the air bob was
so quick he really some of them got to
be a little you know sometimes planned
almost yeah right but you could see the
ones that weren't and how smooth bob is
and how quick he is so I think he was he
was a very funny guy he didn't need the
riders I loved the song though anything
about the song Bob credit him also with
instantly recognizing that song that he
would make that song his own it became
that's the greatest theme song in show
business history it's adaptable to every
situation you know every place he went
he rewrote the lyrics for them you know
for
that's true I've seen a lot of specials
he did where he rewrote the lyrics for
that event that he was at or that
special that he was doing her who he was
standing out there absolutely and you
know I gotta say I'm sure more lyrics
have been written for that song than any
other song in showbusiness history you
know it's funny he was this
he's enigmatic he's this he was
incredibly popular one of the most
popular stars of the 20th century kind
of the American comedian for decades and
yet he also had which might be common
with a lot of comedians he was a hard
nut to crack he he had this slick
exterior and you weren't gonna get
inside you weren't going to find out too
much and I had a personal experience
when I was a writer in the Simpsons and
Johnny Carson had just gone into
retirement he'd been retired for about a
year at that point he agreed to do a
voice on The Simpsons and so I was one
of the writers that was there this was
about a year before I did my own
late-night show and he came in and we
just couldn't believe it and Johnny
Carson came in I'll never forget he had
a Filofax and two fresh packets of
cigarettes and he came in and he sat
down and he recorded his voice and then
he was a little stiff and nervous at
first but then he really relaxed and I
could see that he he was around some
writers and he liked being around these
young writers and so he just started to
I remembered we he was going to sign
some autographs a stack of autographs
and he was doing it he started chatting
with us and he started talking about Bob
Hope and it was clear that he loved he
admired Bob Hope but I'll never forget
this he sort of said you know he started
to confess I tried over the years you
know to get him to open up he'd come on
the show and I say you've known every
president since Hoover yeah you've
entertained for you know you've been you
knew Patton you in World War two and he
goes yeah how about that yeah how about
that yeah and if we ran and Carson as an
interviewer and and I can relate to this
now after 23 years you get someone out
there and you're trying to get them to
open up a little bit and they're just
yeah and that's something yeah and
that's something I could see that he
would be
he's a huge star and he'd come on and
hit you know probably plug what it's
special he was doing but he wasn't about
to open up he it was a performance for
him he he came off his writers would
write him a few jokes he'd have him
prepared and Johnny Johnny really did
not by the end he did not enjoy Bob Hope
as a guest he it was too frustrating for
him what constrained I think Johnny it
probably was the only person that Johnny
had to be completely deferential to yeah
well that was because here's the you
know here is the iconic Bob Hope V NBC
you know the king of NBC for 30 years
and Johnny knew that I have to take care
of him I have to but I can't it's not
like Buddy Hackett it's not like the two
of us are going to just be laughing our
asses off together yeah
we're I need to take care of him and
service this gas it's plus I mean he was
in the later years he was getting hard a
hearing it was it was tough to really
yet to crack Bob Hope it was tough for
anybody it people besides about Johnny
Carson he I didn't find many people who
felt that they were close to Bob Hope I
mean he he didn't have really close
friends this is this is interesting
because it leads me to want to ask about
Bing Crosby you watch these two together
in all these movies that are so iconic
and they're so good together
and they're just peanut butter and jelly
I mean just perfect like these two
should be working together and even as
enormous Lee's sophisticated but I know
I feel like I can't be you know I can
look at people together on screen and
they can look like they get along but I
can assume they don't I swear to you
when I watch these road pictures that
that Bing Crosby and Bob Hope are best
friends in real life and they weren't no
they they weren't I I think it was a it
was a mixed relationship I think they
did love working together and I think
they had a lot of respect for each other
but there were such different kinds of
people
bob was you know very social loved being
a star I love dealing with fans and
everything Bing was much more reclusive
I think much more ambivalent about his
fame
he moved to you know out of he didn't
like the Hollywood scene he moved to
Northern California halfway through his
career and and he didn't show up for
things there was a famous Friars Club
roast for Bob in the late 40s and all
the big stars and comedy stars of
Hollywood were there on the dais I mean
Jack Benny George Burns Georgie Jessel
the whole gang and there was a seat for
Bing Bing didn't show up and I think
that rankled Bob and then someone told
me who worked with him late in life that
that Bob said you know in a candid
moment you know I never liked thing he
was he never in all the years he and you
know he never invited me in Dolores to
dinner yeah that's an odd thing to hear
from now you know I think he you know I
think they were they were friends but
they were not that close and they were
very different kind of people yeah I
think there was also Bing it almost felt
like everything he had been a much
bigger star earlier than Bob Ho right
Bob looked up to Bing a lot Bob modeled
himself after Bing I mean he when he
started he followed being into business
ventures Bing wanted to get into oil
said we got it you know and and Bob Bob
got into oil with bing ba Bob set up his
production company when he set up his
own production company in the mid 40s it
was kind of modeled after one that Bing
had set up to so he admired bit you know
Bing was a very smart businessman thing
was he very smart about California real
estate I think yeah well Bob got Bob but
that's one place where Bob outstripped
Bing yeah because he started buying real
estate up in the late 40s in a lot in
the 50s all the San Fernando Valley real
estate when it was cheap and he at one
time was reputed to be the biggest
private land holder in the state of
California
he he and and got very wealthy because
of that the the real estate and so Bob
Bob really was very smart about real
estate and he was he would go out and he
would
look at the property himself he didn't
just have some business associated go
out and buy stuff he went he he was very
a hands-on as a businessman and and and
when at one time I think was 1968
Fortune magazine did a survey of the
richest people in America and Bob Hope
was the richest person in in Hollywood
in California than any studio mogul
mm-hmm and he didn't like being on that
list that's right
was the one thing he hated talked unlike
some other people today he didn't like
being known as a rich guy he he really
didn't he felt it separated him from the
calm his audience and so he he always
pooh-poohed he always thought the
estimates of his wealth were open that's
way too much that's way too much no he
actually wrote and asked for like a
retraction yeah no I'm not worth what
I'm worth I'm not worth 800 million I'm
more you know and I think he got them to
adjust it somewhat even though to most
people yeah in any era the difference
between 800 and 300 who cares it's
astronomical what he didn't and this is
classic for people that grew up in
poverty he I always heard rumors in my
years in show business people you know
when he was still alive I would hear
rumors I've run into people who would
say oh they had worked with you know
they ran a radio station or a group of
radio stations and they had a thing they
arranged for Bob Hope to come and do
something and so they were gonna pay him
for his transportation but then Bob got
a ride on it someone's you know on a
moguls jet yeah and so they didn't send
the tickets and Bob's people would call
and say send the tickets because we're
gonna cash him in yeah okay that he was
kind of famous for I want to get paid
everything I deserve to get paid you
can't blame him if someone's grown up in
that kind of poverty but even when he
was one of the richest landowners in the
United States mm-hmm there's I know for
a fact people have told me that they'd
see him in the valley going into a
fast-food restaurant being assisted this
is very late in his life but with
coupons yeah because he has these
coupons
for the dollar 20 burger that will make
it only 80 cents and he's gonna get that
burger he was he was cheap and and he
would he would want the receipt from the
guy who you know his band leader had to
take some music across town he want the
receipt from the cab you know to to get
repaid but if that is that's the
depression-era mindset he just he
struggled to make it for many years and
he always had that mindset one of his
writers said you know it's for a guy
like that it doesn't matter how much
real estate you have it's what you got
in your pocket and you know he it was
just a hazy number to him what he was
worth it was abstract yeah and what it
was you know what you could pay for what
you could have you know what you had in
your pocket so he was you know people a
lot of people thought he was cheap he
could also be generous he gave money to
friends and relatives who needed it of
course was very charitable and you know
made that part of his image is his work
for charity and all that of course but I
think it was an odd thing you know he
could be cheap on the one hand he could
be he could dole out you know
thousand-dollar checks on the other so
he was kind of you write about it in the
book at one point he owned a lot of land
in the Santa Monica Mountains and
preservationist wanted him to donate it
and they kind of shamed him into
donating it which I think he resented
yeah that was near the end you know in
his later years when he had all this
land and they were trying to conserve it
for Park Park land and he was trying to
sell it to developers he says I've held
this and and why not he said yeah I've
had this you know I bought I didn't buy
this land you know smartly when I you
know in the 1950s just to give it away
it's appreciated and he wanted to cash
it in he finally did get shamed into at
least selling a lot of it for less than
market value and and and overturning it
over to the state a very shrewd
businessman but Walt Disney approached
him about investing in his new theme
park and Bob Hope said he said no I
don't think anybody's going to go to
Anaheim for place called Disney
yeah Bob he wasn't batting a thousand
I've lived on that story for he also
claimed that he had a chance to get into
Polaroid on the ground floor he's like
nah y'all gonna work out huh like when
the long run he was right that's right
just took a while he always he was NBC
he was worked at NBC for you know pretty
much his entire career if not his entire
you know his career in radio and then
television and he did the specials and
they were hugely successful and then you
got the sense that it it got to a point
when he was getting on in years that NBC
needed to be very delicate about this
maybe the specials aren't rating what
they used to but Bob still wants to do
the specials but you could see that that
was getting to be a bit of a tenuous
situation and something that NBC had to
wanted to handle correctly and it was
not only that the specials the ratings
were going down somewhat although
interestingly they held up for a long
time yeah you know even into his 80s
they were still doing doing well but it
wasn't so much them as much the ratings
as Bob himself was just falling apart or
you know he was having trouble seeing he
was having trouble hearing and finally
he really couldn't do a monologue even
anymore so they were starting to
construct shows for him that would you
know will showcase him as little as
possible Bob presents the new comedians
or something and they would click you
know very ingeniously coming up with
various formats to keep Bob on the air
while he did less and less but he didn't
want to retire he just was so addicted
to the stage and the applause and you
know he he just didn't know what he
won't do without it was his it was his
way of life it's also interesting that
he had he's you know got a talk about
because you talk a lot about this in the
book and it's fascinating to me he
marries is his wife Dolores and it feels
like they have this great relationship
early on and then there's womanizing you
know Bob is kind of a legendary
womanizing
and and everybody knew it I mean it was
just at a time when everybody knew about
it and so Dolores is kind of in the
background for a long time later in life
it feels like she starts to come back
into the foreground you know I think one
of the last things I saw a Bob Hope do
was a Christmas special and Delores is
really carrying the ball as a Christian
specialist right and it takes place in
their home and these different stars are
coming by and it's like yeah the actor
from hanging with mr. Cooper yeah yeah
you know it's always the strangest group
of dingdong who is it oh hey and some of
Bob's kids are there and it's the family
and and you know Joey Lawrence yes and
Joey Lawrence's come by and hello mr.
hope and they give a gift but really the
one carrying all the water is Dolores
because Bob is at that point you can
tell they're doing a lot of extra pickup
shots because he couldn't hear very well
that was the big problem yeah though
they had to carry him but yeah Dolores
did start to take control a little bit I
think she tried to convince him to not
you know just to stop but she couldn't
you know she couldn't if he do try and
get him to stop performing not
performing yeah yeah
and then then Dolores of course started
her own resumed her own singing career
she had been a fairly popular nightclub
singer back in the 30s when Bob met her
and married her and and then at the end
of near the end of his life she picked
it up again and she recorded and when
she was 80 years old and then I've seen
some footage of them performing together
they had a great routine where she gives
him his lyrics and it's one line yeah
how that tiny little and he's even in
even when he's 90 he's performing that
really well yeah yes yeah he still do it
that's right you're really impressed
with how well he's doing it he's turning
over it's just one line and he's turning
over the piece of paper and doing these
great takes to the side and I'm like oh
my god that guy that's just not gonna go
away now he interesting with Dolores he
she had been a performin she stopped
performing when bob was riding high and
but she still for a while she still
would appear on his radio show as a
singer he would always he would bill her
as Delores read
I mean I I think I sometimes he wouldn't
even identify her as his wife really uh
I believe for you know for a little bit
of time but then it'd be he would but
then she stopped appearing but she went
with him on you know the Vietnam trips
well some of the the trips in the 50s
and 60s his trips over his Christian
Crips Delores would go and she would
entertain a lot but she never made it
into the show that when when they'd edit
the show together Delores was never
there really yeah until late his last
Vietnam trip she went on that trip and
then she entertained and he he used her
in the show and I thought that was sort
of symbolic I think in a sense Bob
didn't want to share the spotlight with
his wife and and then by the end though
it was there was some kind of you know
reconciliation or whatever ways that she
could really help yeah - yeah see you
needed her lookit you know you brought
it up and it's it's a huge legacy that
that Bob Hope has which is he invented
this idea of performing for the troops
the USO I mean I'm sure other people had
done some version of it in history but
really Bob Hope made it his own and
what's really surprised me in the book
is I always pictured him you know 200
miles from the front line doing a giant
show I had no idea especially in World
War two how close to the action he was
how hard that how difficult that was and
I mean there there is he's in bombing
raids where he and the other performers
are like huddled in a in a basement and
the bombs are dropping really close I
had no idea I mean I've done us so work
and never been in the slightest
slightest bit of danger and then I read
about what he was doing and realizing
he's pretty much on the frontline and in
some of these World War 2 performing
situations he it seems it feels very
improvised like they're dashing from
Camp to camp and it would be very easy
to get killed or hurt and you
you know this was at the time other
people were entertaining but bob was
nobody was more intrepid than he way he
just he works so hard at it he went
everywhere he would make five stops in a
day then he would have his little little
troupe of performers and they didn't
have an entourage they did they wouldn't
there's almost no film of it in the
first trip to Europe in 1943 right
because they didn't have a camera crew
with them they were just going and
entertaining and they were in North
Africa and then three days after General
Patton succeeded in retaking Sicily for
the Allies Bob hoped three days later
Bob Hope and his troop were there as
close to the front lines as any American
entertainers had ever been and they were
still getting bombing raids from the
German you know planes and there was
several you know air raids and they had
to go into Bates hotel basements and or
they were in jeeps and they had to dive
for cover and it's harrowing and it was
really amazing what he did then he would
also you know he wasn't doing it you
know I think in the it's changed in the
60s with the Vietnam shows I think the
counterculture was upset about Vietnam
war and Bob Hope was always preaching we
want peace we need to unify in this
country and his message wasn't clearly
going over well with younger people in
the 60s that's kind of where you feel
like they started to part company but in
World War two and in the Korean War he's
really dedicated in this way that's
sweet and inspiring as you've described
it in the book he means it he's not
doing it for himself or for the glory he
you get this sense that he really is
driven to do this because it's the right
thing to do and you have a story in here
about him finishing a big show and
finding out that some troops I tried to
get in but couldn't and went 30 miles
the other way back to their camp and so
he took his people and went 30 miles and
found them and did a show for them it's
amazing
which practically makes me cry it's so
sweet you know he loved it because they
were great audiences they loved him
they were easy audiences but you know he
knew how much it meant to them I mean
these are guys at the front lines that
just come from battles maybe they've
seen their you know comrades killed and
and here's Bob Hope the biggest comedy
star in America's standing in front of
them I mean you read some of the letters
from from servicemen who watched him and
he's you can just feel you know how much
that meant and then and Bob got that and
and it was so meaningful to him and it
was a time World War two of course where
there was no controversy about the war
the country rally behind it there was no
you know you went over and entertained
the troops you were patriotic American
Bob unfortunately didn't field see that
the times have changed in Vietnam and
you know he thought he was doing the
same thing and he didn't realize quite
the depth of the anti-war sentiment I
think the troops in Vietnam still
appreciated him everyone I talked to who
saw him in Vietnam you know appreciating
you know we love seeing Bob Hope but he
started talking about the war you know
he didn't he crossed the line from being
a patriot to sort of a partisan he
really was talking up the war we got to
go in and win the war and he would
badmouth the war protect protesters yeah
you know they're if they're disloyal he
got very friendly with Nixon mm-hmm
Nixon used to bring him into the White
House for briefings to tell him Bob this
is why I'm bombing North Vietnam and
expect that Bob would then go out to the
country and convey the message which I
which he did it's always good to clear
your foreign policy with a comedian yeah
and you know welke see Nixon realized
what a forest Bob Hope was in the
country he wanted Bob Hope behind him
you know it's funny the big question is
since you get about Bob Hope is that he
had this amazing this great career and
then it's it feels like he's overstayed
his welcome a certain period of time
which a lot of performers do and I may
be doing now but you you you stick
around he stuck around and the times
changed and he couldn't stop and you
people we mentioned him already but
Johnny Carson had such a perfect ear for
when I'm gonna get out now I'm gonna
step off this incredible achievement I'm
gonna suspend a step off just at this
moment and I'm going to recede and
there's gonna be this just reverence
which I think Bob Hope was almost too
visible all the time he was too
available
you know you know everything started to
fall apart the the movies got worse and
worse they got to be kind of a joke by
this you talk about in the 1960s what do
you think you you identify his last good
movie in here and I can't remember which
last good movie was the facts of life
yeah say 1960 with Lucille Ball right
what's his favorite co-star and he did
well with her that was a nice film kind
of an adult romantic comedy and Bob you
know showed a little bit of range there
and then he started making the call me
Bwana's and I'll take Sweden's and and
really pretty crumby and and he was
walking through them to the to look at a
Bob Hope performance from the 60s versus
one from the early 40s
oh there's such a difference in the
performer not just he's a little paunchy
or and older but the the the commitment
to the role in the early for I mean he
was into it he everything was heightened
you know to the to the to the max and in
the 60s he's chenna just walking through
and rattling off the lines and one of
his directors said you know he he
doesn't he comes in and he doesn't know
his lines it's sometimes I think he
hasn't even read the script you know
yeah there was one director of one of
his films who said he he would purposely
try to reshoot scenes like pretend like
there was a technical flaw you got to do
it again Bob because by the sixth or
seventh time Bob would have fun to
memorize the figure that his lie but up
until then it's the light wasn't quite
right there was and and the TV the cue
card reading got to be more obvious and
so Bob was kind of walking through it
and then the times changed and that kind
of that's
style of comedy that that great American
unifying comedian who everybody listens
to you know that was fine in the fifth
40s and 50s and you know even into the
early 60s but by the end of the sixties
no he was a divisive figure and yeah you
know maybe there was he outlived the
period when you could have won great all
you know all inclusive comedian he
toured relentlessly and worked
relentlessly I mean he passed away he
was over 100 he was 100 exactly 100 okay
so I mean I think he was still working
until how late yeah well it was 90 in
into his early 90s he had this big 90th
birthday party right a cbnbc had an big
90th birthday special for him three
hours special a lot of stars
it's famously the only time Johnny
Carson after he left his show Johnny
only did one other model stamp a comedy
monologue and it was for Bob Hope's
birth sure yeah that was the last time
Johnny did a stand-up comedy monologue
anyway that was a big show and I betcha
NBC figured and that will be it that
will be but no Bob wanted to keep going
and so they kept going for a few years
more years didn't they then didn't he
how did it end with NBC
well then finally I think they had some
very quiet discussions with the family
and with Bob and with the help of the
family they finally got Bob to agree to
do one last show and it was in 1996 when
Bob would have been 93 mm-hm and it was
Tony Danza hosted it it was Bob Hope
laughing with the presidents and it was
tied in with a book that he had just
come out with Bob Hope and the president
it's just putting together little
stories about presidents and Tony does
most of the heavy lifting in the show
Bob sits there and they do a little
interviewing and you can tell it's
heavily edited right but and that was it
that was the last special I have asked
that when my time is up that Tony Danza
he has agreed he's gonna he's gonna do
it he
you know I had I think you know this
story but I when I was writing on The
Simpsons one day and this just shows you
how much the culture had changed but I
want to say it was about 1990 I'm
sitting around with all the writers in
the writers room of the Simpsons and Al
Jean I think came into the room and said
alright Bob Hope's agreed to do a tape a
voice for us so who wants to go to his I
need some you know two writers to go
over to his Toluca Lake home to look
like you have to look like Kourt is
Toluca Lake home and record Bob Hope's
voice now I just thought they'd be a mad
scrum of everyone trying to go to hands
went up and only two hands and it was it
was myself and Jeff Martin both of us
are just our hands went up like we get
to meet Bob Hope you know get to go to
Bob Hope's house everyone else was kind
of like yeah we're good yeah which I
couldn't believe
no so we drove over and we were led in
and we were told mr. hope will be with
you in a bit and we were on our own and
I remembered walking around this paneled
library with pictures of everybody yeah
I mean everybody and bound copies of his
scripts and then looking out the back
window and seeing a putting green you
know in his backyard and just being in
awe of the whole thing and then hearing
people coming and it was his daughter
who I think served as his kind of
producer yeah at the time
Linda Linda and a few other people and
we set up our tech stuff and remember he
could barely hear us I don't think he
could see very well and got a quick
handshake and oh yeah all right what do
we know any a lot of what what and I
think getting mad at his daughter and we
were getting a little embarrassed and I
thought we're not seeing the Bob Hope
where the scene is very old man and I
think I told you this but I thought yeah
I didn't get my Bob Hope moment I just
you know we recorded his line which was
I think at one point he's for reasons
that I can't remember he's hanging off a
helicopter rudder Lisa Simpson
in the car and he shouts up dropped me
off of that Boat Show he's just you know
and he's got his golf club they just
dropped me off of that Boat Show I'm
gonna go make some money over there and
that was the iconic line we want him to
say is yeah and so he did it we had him
say it a couple of times I think we had
to explain to him what the joke was ah
you know and then he's leaving if I
didn't get my Bob Hope woman and one of
his attendants this guy came up to him
and I heard as Bob Hope was walking out
towards the stairwell to go upstairs he
said to him about one of the dogs mr.
hope I'm afraid it's time for us to put
whatever the dog's name was it's time
for us to put bow-wow down you know look
so that's I just talked to the vets time
to put bow-wow down I mean and Bob Hope
just won that's a shame
better let me tell him and I remember
just thinking like I got it I mean it
was while he was walking away better let
me tell him and I just had this night
moment of and I was appreciative I
really you know was excited to see Bob
Hope and be even in a slight tiny way
connected to that amazing history and I
think that was 1990 he went on to live
quite a while after that did the last
few years he was kind of out of it but
but he worked till 93 94 Bill Clinton
told me a story about playing golf with
Bob Hope when Clinton was in there was a
famous edition of the Hope Classic in
Palm Springs the golf tournament were
three presidents played with Bob Hope in
a foursome Ford Bush Senior and and
Clinton and not long after that Bill
Clinton is in the White House and gets a
call from Bob Hope or his assistant I
presume Bob wants to know if you can
play golf this afternoon the President
of the United States and Clinton said
you know I actually had some time on my
schedule the book to the closest course
to the White House wherever it is in
Virginia somewhere went over and played
golf with Bob Hope for nine holes he
said this is a guy he was 91 or
something at the time he could barely
see the ball
you could not see where he the his
assistant had to line him up you know
and he he tells me about there was a
three a three part
hole that was toughened by Clinton who
has a great memory was telling me
exactly how the hole was and there was a
slope to the right-hander and hope gets
on and he drives onto the green twenty
feet from the pin they walk up to the
green the assistant lines up Bob for the
pot Clinton says I tell him Bob it's 20
feet it's slightly uphill with a break
to the right okay you can't see he putts
the ball two feet the two inches from
the from the top taps it in for a par he
said that's pretty amazing and that's
incredible to ninety one or two so what
do you think obviously we we live in
this world now of there's 10,000 comedic
voices out there and you know comics
probably you know crop up they're gone I
sometimes don't know how much you know
how much thought there is about the
history of comedy or what came before us
I wonder and you might be able to shed
some light on it was what will the
legacy of Bob Hope be or is there even
such a thing in comedy well you know
when people ask me why I wrote this book
is it's partly because I had done
another book on stand-up comedy in the
70s the the George Carlin Richard Pryor
era and when talking to all those guys
down through Jerry Seinfeld and and
nobody ever mentioned Bob
it just seemed he's so off the radar so
III you know I felt he was not properly
appreciated that's why I wrote the book
I felt I was on a mission
what's his legacy I mean people have to
go back today you write his comedy is
not what people do think of a stand-up
comedy today today it's it's a different
style and you listen to some of those
early radio shows it's pretty corny
stuff I mean Bob Hope's monologues it'd
be hard to sort of pull out lines and
say what a great line that one but he
was a comedian of the time and as I say
innovators we have to respect the
innovators who you know in their time
discover something new and Bob Hope
discovered something
new he he discovered that topical
monologue and he he also discovered what
I think his legacy is almost as much for
what he did off screen as on screen I
think the way he sort of conducted
himself as a celebrity he was he was a
guy who had a had a role on the public
stage you know he would he was a star
who who did public service who
entertained the troops who work for
charity he said I think he said to you
know by example he said to his fellow
Hollywood stars you're famous you're a
famous Hollywood star you have an
obligation to do more than just make
movies and sign autographs and buy a
fancy home in Malibu you have an
obligation to use your celebrity to do
good to give back in some sense to have
a role on the public stage so I think
the whole generation of current
generation of activists Hollywood stars
George Clooney Angelina Jolie etc I
think they owe a debt to Bob Hope um he
made it safe for stars to be taken
seriously as public figures mm-hmm and
you know the political views are
different the causes are different but
you know he made it he paved the way so
that's I think a big part of his legacy
yeah he was I mean even his I think
about this when when I first went to
entertain troops I obviously went and
looked at what did Bob Hope do because
there's got to be and sure enough it's
all he he tells you what to do through
example which is prepare know what
you're getting into do your research do
some reconnaissance and find out where
the you know who's the base commander
who you know the Marines who are they
like to laugh at well they like to laugh
at you know the different branches
what's their take on each other and know
that so if you're talking to the Navy
you know to make fun of the army if
you're talking to the army you make fun
of the Navy and I was really impressed
with how much and it's in the it's in
your book how much reconnaissance he did
he had really knew he worked really hard
so that when he entertained the troops
on those bases it was a personal
experience he was making jokes where he
told them I understand
what your life is like right I know your
base commander's a tight ass I know that
the food stinks and who get specifics
and then he could bring out Raquel Welch
always a good idea he really felt they
felt he was talking their language and
he was think he would send those riders
out a few days before and they would
they would find out what the buzz on the
on the base was he did it in his all his
concerts if he was going to st. Louis he
would find out what the mayor you know
what what the latest scandal was and
you'd have a joke about the mayor or the
local you know restaurant or whatever so
everybody was amazing to read through
his fan mail you know he got a ton of
fan mail i I don't it's hard to know but
I bet he got more fan mail than any
anybody and as it was amazing how much
he answered mm-hmm he answered and
certainly have assistants who were
writing it up but I saw all these in his
in his massive boxes full of letters
that there at the Library of Congress
now and it was you you you knew that a
secretary was typing this up but so many
of these letters had a personal response
yeah yeah yeah I remember the Toledo
that I played the Hippodrome Theatre in
1930 you know things like that that he
had to be dictating me he had to
physically be there and connecting yes
right and every person who got a letter
back from Bob Hope like that you know
there was a fan for life it was the
greatest grassroots politician four of
any entertainer I think and he never
considered politics he no he didn't I
think there was a time when some people
were kind of talking Bob you ought to in
the late 60s but he I don't think he
really wanted you know get into politics
you know he resisted that there's no
money in it yeah well this book is a
real pleasure and I'm so glad you wrote
it I'm so glad that I this sounds
apocryphal but it's this is an
absolutely true story when I first came
out to Los Angeles in 1985 my writing
partner Greg Daniels and I had our first
meeting where we were going to get a
and they handed us a contract they
wanted us to sign before we signed it
Greg and I went back to our little
apartment on Barrington in Brentwood and
we were studying this contract in it we
had never seen a contract before and it
said acts of God and you know all the
different boilerplate that's in there
and we came back and we were ready to
sign and we said we'd like to put a Bob
Hope clause in there and I remember at
our age at the time somebody talked
about and I said we just want one thing
in there that says should Bob Hope die
during the course of during the time of
this contract that it's void because
he's been such a big part of the comedy
landscape that all the rules will no
longer exist and of course we were half
kidding but we're remembered as pushing
this agent on the Bob Hope clause in
1985 he was like shut the [ __ ] are first
job and we were being wise asses but I
want to say half of it kind of felt true
like Bob Hope had such had so much been
the complete background and yeah he had
been such a big part and such an
institutional figure that we thought can
we get this one clause in there whether
for some reason something crazy happens
to Bob open the next month this is all
off well we didn't get it yeah well I'm
glad that I really felt a sense of
mission about writing the book and I'm
glad that people like you because
they're not that many who will comedians
out there who will talk so fondly about
Bob Hope and they should they should
this is the guy who invented their art
form I yeah well to fix that I will
implore and demand that this is this is
not a homework assignment it's just a
great book it is a page-turner and it's
not just this is not just a book about a
guy named Bob Hope I think to a large
degree this is a book about the 20th
century in America it is it takes you
through when you think about the span of
time that Bob Hope lived through he
lives through vaudeville the explosion
of radio movies television and he his
life ended not long ago I mean and he
encompasses pretty much I mean
everything except for the internet
that's everything and if you if you want
to get all of that the experience of
show business you have to read this book
hope is is out there
Richard za Glenn thank you so much for
writing the book and then for agreeing
to talk to me about it in this very
creepy room great yeah thanks so much
Jeff yeah let's see the route I had this
measured so that I could reach over and
shake people's things you can't do that
on Charlie Rose you're not allowed to
touch him cuz he's not really there
alright this is Connor O'Brien if you
want to check out other jibber jabbers
go to team koco.com and then press Alt
Delete 9 that last part I made up just
fine jibber jabber there's a lot of
great interviews and these are labors of
love these are only people I really want
to talk to about books and things that
really excite me so thank you so much
very nice